mais attends mais t'as pas du tout la
même peut-être qu'en photo ah ouais bah
ouais t'es mis en photo ouais mais bon
en photo sa claque est là comment ça va
désolé mon max on chantait ça va
c'est pas bien
horrible à dire mais ce que j ai dit
allô papa je travaille moi que mon mari
mais oui ce jour 100 m tu as poney sa
fin et là j'ai jamais dit si tu veux
comme j'ai 28 ans le jour
même les ans
mais j'ai très très belle tassé sur
ouais mais bon là je suis tellement
content
quand un patient limites et là c'est
plus cher du toulouse ont besoin d'un
mari richard jones a bien clair parce
que je suis extrêmement dépensèrent qui
pétillent des couleurs et en voix m'a
quand même des relevés de franck non non
ça vers les côtes
ca c
[Musique]
j'aime bien les vrais grands mecs un peu
baraki saint-élie renoir j'aime bien les
renoir vient d'amener un barack
toutefois quoi tu peux te chauffer sur
des points à 3 des trucs comme ça demain
que se chauffer et de make up
pas de mec qui venait sûr c'est que je
crois que le missionnaire pas oublier ça
bouge tellement vénère
je
merci parce que j'avais pris mais j'ai
un problème de pilules en ce moment
je suis vraiment désolé est toujours nul
pendant